taystee oh it's Andrea again from a-z
this is Andrea from Arizona and I you
know unfortunately I don't know if I
remember the first time you called
Andrea but thank you for calling back
more well you have to you gotta ask a
first question before you ask a second
one you know I don't know how much
gasoline you're gonna get let's go more
you know do you like I imagine you like
them all shapes and colors but what type
of personality do you like in a girl you
know do you like her to be funny like
you or or docile and quiet
I appreciate you again and I thank you
for calling Andrea I appreciate you as
well do out like I'm docile I mean I
don't like I'm under the influence of
you know quaaludes or anything like that
you know I don't want a girl you have to
you know when you get home you got to
take her out of the trunk and bring her
in the house so I like a girl you know I
don't mind a pigtail I don't I don't
mind two pigtails you know I remember
this one girl only have one pigtail a
month in my neighborhood because they
only had one bar rat at her house and
they got her and her sister got a set of
barrettes for Christmas but the set only
come with two barrettes and so they each
got to use one so they running around
each and look each looking like you know
half a Wendy's logo because each one of
them had that just one you know that one
stray that one braid riding now you know
like I just like a like a diving board
that was you know taking the afternoon
off just kind of hanging off that side
you know hanging out so I don't mind a
little bit of braids I like a
hard-working woman you know I don't want
any of these I don't need I need a
teammate I need a partner in crime you
know I like a woman that knows that life
is hard work I like a woman for me I
think that has some semblance of idea or
thoughts of
there being some sort of a higher power
that doesn't have to be they don't need
to believe in Jesus Christ they don't
need to believe in you know in Muhammad
or something a specific deity or a
specific liaison to a religion but I
need them to you know I want them to
believe that there's something greater
out there than us you know I'm sayin I
ain't friggin backpack ain't carrying
around no atheist I just can't you know
because for me that doesn't work for
some people that may and that's okay if
it works for you but I don't want
somebody you know where every other day
feels like Halloween around the house
cuz they dark art what else do I like
you know I dated a girl with a real
small head one time I wouldn't mind more
of like a regular headed woman I dated a
girl had this little pen top you know
what sometime when you were when I was
making out whether I could kiss her and
my hands would touch under her chin and
on the top of her head at the same time
and she was an adult obviously and but I
remember just like Tang she got that
little she got that cabbage ball you
know I started thinking how many I how
many ideas could she even have in this
in this thing in this hitter you know on
top of her neck you know yeah I was
always scared somebody with a t-ball bat
was just gonna roll up and just you know
try to knock a double cuz she had that
look that little baby you know you know
that looks that little you know that
little you know mediocre sphere but she
was a beautiful girl
I mean I think she was probably the she
might have been the prettiest girl in
New Orleans but she inch and you know uh
but who knows man to do I like you know
I like a woman that's a hard worker I
like a woman that's a hard worker and I
want a woman that could be a mother you
know I don't want one of these whiny-ass
ladies talking about you know preaching
all the time about you know motherhood
and this and that when they don't even
have any children I want a woman who
doesn't mind having some children you
know and who doesn't mind having some
children with me I'm not looking for
some housewife my wife can have a job my
wife can be a CEO my wife can be
President of the United States
that's fine with me but I would hope
that if we can have children that we
have them so that's something
what kind of ladies I'm like if I'm just
thinking about being Randi you know I
like uh you know I like I mean I'm when
I was young I dated you know I like that
kind of native-american looking tight
kind of girl like if you saw her you
know if you walk by and she was wearing
a little bit of you know you know if you
peeped in time if you were peeking in
her windows and she didn't know you were
there she might have had on those you
know that buffalo skin brassiere you
know she might have had a couple of duck
uterus that's kind of woven in with some
vine and holding up her breasts you know
just some lady that's really of the
earth you know that Native American kind
of kind of girl if you peeking in her
window at night you wouldn't be
surprised for dad freaking drop that
arrow right by year you know parted your
hair just wrong and you know not to look
at his daughter get you know changed
clothes and stuff at night even though
you guys are in love with each other so
I think I had that kind of Pocahontas
sort of thing that I kind of always
maybe envisioned you know and my mother
you know they say that you're attracted
to some characteristics that your mother
has and my mother was kind of uh
was sort of kind of tall dark and
handsome I guess in a way but in a
female way my mother's a hard worker
the hardest-working man I've ever known
is my mother and so I you know I really
admire that you know I need because I
need a teammate and I'm a lot to deal
with I know that you know I'm really
sensitive you know I'm a sensitive
person and I get better at managing my
sensitivity but I still I need
somebody's got that so you know who's
able to follow you know who's able to
deal with that so but also you know I
think it changes over time you know and
you some things I start to see if one
good thing about being you know single
as you get older and being able to kind
of see how relationships shake out and
stuff is that you notice like oh I'm
glad I didn't go with that one I'm glad
I didn't go with that one or I'm you
know where I'm not I'm that I didn't go
but I'm glad
when that situation didn't work out or
that situation didn't work out because
of this or because of that you know you
start to see like oh I see how that how
that person goes that way or how that
type of person goes that way you just
get more view so that's one thing that
is kind of rewarding about being single
as I get older it's being able to get a
larger a larger view of what's going on
but you know I you know I've been
fortunate enough to date today some neat
gals you know I hope I haven't in my
life I don't know if I've ever
mistreated any women or done anything
like that you know I think I've been
afraid of commitment and those sorts of
things and so that probably hadn't been
very helpful to some women but but those
are some things that I like you know and
for me of a woman's funny that's
beautiful to me if a woman is if a woman
likes to play board games sometimes in
the evening or in the afternoon then I
like that you know I like a girl that
doesn't mind you know maybe doing like a
silly dance or something or doesn't mind
like you know looking silly sometimes
because those things inspire me you know
I'm always so afraid to like you know
it's kind of weird I'm afraid to look
silly like I'm not afraid to tell jokes
and say things that are silly but I'm
afraid physically sometime to look silly
and so if there's a girl that kind of is
comfortable with those sorts of things
then that makes me feel I you know I
admire that because I wish I could be
that way and then somebody that's
understanding I mean [ __ ] I think I'm
just describing things we all want but
that's some of my ideas Andrea and you
sound like a beautiful young lady and if
I don't have somebody or if you don't
have somebody then at the very least you
know you still treat ourselves with
romance so once you get out there and
put some damn you know put some of that
tzatziki on your thighs you know and
treat yourself right you know light a
candle and
or some wax on your neck or something
you know or dip your shoulders in
chocolate and lick it off do that side
to side you know they're freaking
nervous that'd be that with that nervous
tongue just hunting your freaking
clavicle hunting along your clavicle
with that nervous tongue just back and
forth back and forth
I'm just getting your own chocolate hits
some beauty right there